[MUSIC PLAYING]
TERRY RYAN: My
name is Terry Ryan.
I'm a Developer Advocate
for Google Cloud Platform.
And this is going to be
Google Cloud Platform 101.
My goal here-- actually,
before I get started in goals
and explain stuff, I want
to know a little bit more
about you, who you guys are.
So how many people here
develop on a daily basis?
All right.
And how many people here do
systems work on a daily basis?
OK.
And how many people do both?
OK, is it because
you love DevOps?
Hands.
Is it because your bosses hate
you and won't hire more people?
OK.
Anybody here tell
developers or systems
people what to do, like
any managers in the room?
Whoa, I should have checked that
before I made a manager joke,
shouldn't I have?
All right, well, luckily when
you move to Google Cloud,
you can kind of relieve your
workers, so that's good.
All right, that
kind of gives you
a good idea of who you guys
are and what's going on.
Actually, I'm going to
ask one more question.
How many people are currently on
Google Cloud Platform already?
OK.
How many people have
tried containers already?
Great.
How many people have tried some
sort of serverless solution
already?
All right, great.
Good mix.
I'm really, really excited.
All right, so what are
my goals for this talk?
My goals for this talk are
to tour Google Cloud Platform
from the perspective of someone
moving their first app over
to GCP.
And that usually entails a
particular set of processes,
and it's challenging.
Onboarding to a new system
is always difficult.
So I really feel
passionate about this.
I really like to help bring
people onto the cloud easier.
My secondary goal, which
is not as important to me,
is to explain all of the
various things available in GCP.
It's just too much.
It would take too long.
I'd be like an auctioneer.
So instead, what I'm to
do is as I go through,
and we migrate
this app over, I'm
going to point out
certain touchpoints.
Like it makes sense that
we talk about storage,
and we talk about
other computing things
other than just
virtual machines,
although that's what I'll be
focused on, virtual machines.
So OK, one other thing
I want to announce
is that we have an
internal tool called
Dory which does
question and answers
during our big meetings.
So when Sundar, is answering
questions internal meetings
at Google, he uses
this tool we use
to kind of surface our issues.
It is available in the app,
so if you go to the app
and go to the session,
you can actually do live--
like basically ask questions
while I'm speaking.
I will go back after the talk--
at the end of the
talk, we'll have
Q&A. And if your
question does not
get answered during the talk,
I guarantee to you personally
that I will go through and
make sure they're all answered.
So please, if you're interested,
please participate in that.
And we'll have live
Q&A at the end.
All right, so how do
people move to the cloud?
Most times, when they
try out a new cloud,
they do pretty much
the same thing.
They pick up an app
they have somewhere else
and they just try to
move it to the cloud
and see what happens, right?
We call this the lift and shift.
Just moving stuff, making
it exactly the same as it
was, just somewhere else.
So I have a demo of
a minimum viable app.
I'm going to switch
over to the demo laptop.
And we'll drive.
So this is a very minimal app.
It basically is a tagging
app for photos, right?
So I have these photos here.
I'm going to go through and
add one, just to show you
this is a live system.
I'm going to go through
and say OK and upload.
We're going to add some tags.
I may have done this repeatedly
to the point where my browser
just gives me these options.
I'll hit Upload, it's there.
It's all saved.
All right, there it is.
So we have a list of pictures.
We have a list of
tags that humans
create to tag those pictures.
Pretty easy, pretty
straightforward, pretty simple.
We're going to switch
back to the presentation.
All right.
And let's just talk
about the architecture.
So I know none of you guys,
non of you folks in this room,
have ever done--
like you've put all
your stuff on a single server
and run your production
app off a single server.
No one here does that.
But we all know people
that have done this, right?
So this is what we're
going to use as a stand-in
for moving a real application.
It's pretty simple.
It's got application code.
It's written in PHP.
It's got a database to store
all the tagging information,
and it's got file storage in
order to serve up the images.
We're going to move
it to this, where
we have a single server that
only runs the application code.
And all of the stateful stuff
is moved to a cloud provided
database and images.
And then we'll
take it from there
and go and do more
things with it.
So let's talk about
our virtual machines,
because that is really
where this starts, right?
You want to run this code
on a virtual machine,
just on our network.
So Compute Engine is the tool
for running virtual machines
on Google Cloud Platform.
You can get 1 to 96 processors,
0.6 to 624 gigs of RAM.
You can go 65 terabytes
of persistent storage,
3 terabytes of attached SSD,
and 208 gigs of RAM disk.
Instead of talking about
all the features and stuff,
I actually am just--
we're going to build a VM
right in front of you.
So I'm going to switch
to the laptop again.
We're going to be doing
that back and forth.
And so this is Google
Cloud Platform's console.
I'm going to go ahead and
create a new instance here.
And you'll see, here I can
go, and let's give it a name
so I remember--
I remember to delete me.
I'm going to delete it.
And you see I can put
it in any region I want
that we have a data center.
I'm going to choose central,
because that is the one that
is best for the demo.
And I have a number of zones.
So the first thing
I do is I start
to make the shape
of the machine--
how many processors, how
much memory is in it?
But let's say I have a
thing where like, well,
16 is too low.
I'll be performance bound.
And 32 would be overkill,
because I would be
paying for stuff I don't need.
I really need 24.
One of the things you
can do on our platform,
which I really love,
is you can just
dial into exactly the number
of cores you want, right?
So I could say, I
want 24 processors.
That way I'm not paying
you for stuff I don't use
and I get the
performance I need.
I'm going to switch
back, though,
because I don't need
that many processors.
I can go and change
my disk image.
And you'll see that I have a
whole bunch of flavors of OS--
Ubuntu, CoreOS,
Container-Optimized OS,
Red Hat, all the
down here, Windows.
Yes, you can run Windows
on Google Cloud Platform.
I'm going to stick
with what I've got,
because I like the defaults.
Let's see, what else
am I going to do?
Oh, let's see.
When I go to
Customize, something
I didn't show you before is that
if I want to, I can add GPUs.
I can also set a minimum
processor platform.
So if I need the features
of certain processors,
I can get that on my VMs.
I'm going to switch
back to basic, though.
And then one of the last
things I'm going to do
is I'm going to
allow HTTP traffic.
I'm actually going to
open up a firewall rule.
This is the only firewall rule
we have right available, right
when you're creating.
Because it makes sense.
It's HTTP, you always
have to kind of expose--
you very often have
to expose this.
One other thing I
want to show you
here is that at
the bottom-- this
is another one of my
favorite feature of this.
At the bottom, it
says Equivalent REST
or Command Line.
If I click on this,
I actually get
the command line commands
to create this VM exactly
as I've configured it here.
But I can then take that, reuse
it, dump it into my scripts,
and build a fleet of
machines if I want to.
So I can use this to
learn the CLI, which
is really kind of helpful.
And then one last thing.
I love this.
We have Run in Cloud Shell.
I'm going to show Cloud
Shell, because it's one
of my favorite parts of GCP.
I'm actually
spinning up a VM that
is only just like a command
control center kind of VM.
It has all the tools to run
Google Cloud, like right there.
And it's got a
persistent home disk.
So I can do things
like, I don't know,
gcloud compute instance list.
And all the tools are there.
And so I can basically
use all of the tools
to run Google Cloud
Platform right on this Cloud
Shell, which is great, because
now I can maintain and monitor
my whole systems
without having to get
all the stuff on my laptop.
For example, I was working
on one of the demos.
If you've been to the
showcase, we all worked on that
and it was really hard.
One of the problems
I had, though,
was that I needed to
build something in Python.
And I don't have the
right version of Python
on my machine.
And installing the right
version of Python on my machine
was evidently just
more than I could do.
But what was great was
that Cloud Shell already
has that all set up
and it already works.
And so I was just able to
pop over to Cloud Shell,
get my work done, and
do stuff without having
to muck with my laptop.
So it was great.
OK, so I'm going to
go and create this VM.
And we like to say they take
tens of seconds to start up.
In my hotel room testing this
before, it takes 10 seconds.
When people are watching,
it takes longer.
And I don't know how it knows.
So like look away, look away.
All right, so delete means
it's going to be up in now.
All right.
So eh, it's somewhere
in the 10 second range.
I'm going to call it that.
So another great thing
about the console
is I'm going go SSH
into my machine.
And I didn't pull down
any certs, or at least
not me manually.
I didn't pull down any certs.
I didn't have to
hook up anything.
Basically, it's available
right within the browser.
And again, this is great.
I can SSH into these
machines, even if I'm not
at my home workstation.
Let's see.
So just to show this
is real, at get update.
Got to spell it right.
And oh yeah, that's right.
I always forget that
you have to sudo it.
There we go.
I probably pissed off half
the people in the room
with that pronunciation
of sudo, sorry.
Little nerve wracking up here.
All right, so there we go.
So we've gone through,
we've created a machine.
Let's now switch back to the
live preso and talk about it.
So creating a
machine is relatively
easy and straightforward.
GCloud is the tool you use to
interact with most of Google
Cloud Platform, gcloud compute
instances create, and then
you can create
whatever you want.
And the next thing is to--
after I create a machine,
I need to run commands on it.
I need to install software.
I need to configure things.
So gcloud compute ssh, the
name of the virtual machine,
and then whatever
command you've got.
And then to get stuff from
your machine to your VM,
to get the code on
it, you're going
to want to run the gcloud
compute sep, and then source
and destination, just like
you would with SEP normally.
So with these three commands,
I can do everything I need,
right?
I can build a machine.
I can install all the proper
software I need on it.
And then I can push my
application code to it.
Now, obviously, there
are different way--
you can do all this differently,
but this just is bare bones,
like let's just--
the easiest way to get it done.
We can do this.
So I don't like to
talk about price,
but I feel like with
VMs and our technology,
price is an important
differentiator.
So I want to talk
about it a little bit.
I promise I won't
get too salesy.
So one of the
things that we do is
when you start configuring
machines, up in the right
half side of the screen,
you see an estimate, right?
And as I add resources,
I add more processors,
the cost per month goes up.
And it goes up.
And I'll go, I
went crazy, right?
Because Google pays for
these when I spin them up,
so I like to make them big.
And you'll see
I've got a charge.
Now, when you break down the
charge, one of the things
that we do, and it's
really important to know,
is that we have a base
charge if you're just
running your machine
kind of haphazardly.
But if you run your machine for
a consistent period of time,
up to a month--
a month being 100% of
the time you need to run,
and then the next month you
get another sustained use
discount-- we will knock
a significant portion
off the price,
because we appreciate
having consistent load size.
We appreciate being
able to plan better.
Because you have a set
size that you're going
to keep running in perpetuity.
Now, this is great.
Sustainable use
discount is great.
And like for things you
want running all the time,
it's really good.
But there's another option
we should talk about,
which is called preemptable VMs.
And you'll notice that's
significantly less.
But there's a catch, right?
Because there's
got to be a catch.
The catch is that a
preemptable VM, which
is what-- you have to flip a
little setting and it becomes
preemptable.
Preventable VMs will disappear
sometime in the next 24 hours.
And they're guaranteed
to go away in 24 hours.
But they can go away anytime.
So I have literally
started up a preemptable VM
and then went to SSH
into it and it's gone.
And I was completely confused.
So why would you want these?
Well, a lot of
times, we have work
that we need to do kind
of whenever it gets
done batch work, big data jobs.
Well, you can push those jobs.
As long as you have some
sort of queue set up that
can be tolerant of a
machine going down,
you can do them for 1/5
the cost of the normal way
of doing that operation.
As long as soon as the machine
goes down, the queue holds,
you can always request
another machine.
There's nothing stopping
you from requesting
another preemptable machine.
And then boom, you're
going through your queue
at a pretty good rate, and
doing it at 1/5 the cost.
Or you could just spin up five
times the number of machines
and get it done in
1/5 the time, I think.
My math is a little
bit hokey there.
All right, so I talked
about disk images.
We provide disk images, but
you can create your own.
Typically, what I do is
start with one of our images,
modify, customize, make
it unique to what I want,
and then freeze it.
And then I can
create new machines
from that, which
is really helpful.
But I could also make
them from scratch
using virtual bots in a
process that I have never done.
So good luck, but
it can be done.
IP addresses-- you can
get private and public IP
addresses.
You can definitely turn
off public IP addresses.
You can also get
static or ephemeral.
One of the things I like is
when you get an ephemeral IP
address from us, if
something happens and someone
shares that
ephemeral IP address,
and now that's the permanent
IP address of the install,
and you're like but this
could go away anytime,
you can make any one of
our ephemeral IP addresses
just static.
You can just say, give me
that, and that's mine now,
which is great.
Or you can just
have a static one.
Now, they don't
cost you anything
unless you take a static
one and then park on it.
Because we're all trying to
avoid the IP4 apocalypse,
right?
So we want to make sure
that if you have addresses,
you're using them.
Firewall-- briefly
talked about that.
You create a rule.
Open port 3306 on TCP.
And then you give that
rule a tag, a name.
So that would be
MySQL, for those
who are play along at home.
And then you tag machines
with those rules.
And that's how you
open up the firewall.
We'll take a slight detour
and talk about Cloud Shell.
I really love Cloud Shell.
It's a great developer tool.
It's a really great
way of not having
to have this stuff on
your machine all the time.
I didn't show it, but there's
actually a code editor
that you can use,
so you can actually
add code on the fly
in reasonable syntax
highlighting everything.
Really helpful when
you're in a pinch,
when people are calling
you and you are not
near your computer, or
your own personal computer.
All right, we're back.
There's one last consideration
I want to talk about.
I'm talking about our VMs and
our network and our setup.
When you create one of
our VMs on our network,
you don't have to do any
setup to make one data center
talk to another.
By default, in one
project, all your machines
talk to one another.
And they use our really, really
high powered backend network
to do that.
And so instead of having
to go to a different zone
and find, oh, this data
center has these machines,
and then this data has--
they're all in one project.
And so this means you
can do crazy, fun things,
especially with our network.
So I'm going to
switch over to a demo.
And I want to take a
selfie, if that's OK.
I'm going to take a
selfie with all of you.
I hope that's OK.
If it's not, we'll blur
out faces eventually.
That's OK, no one's--
all right, so here we are.
We're going to-- and boom.
Yeah, all right.
And so let me--
this was the test, right?
I am clearly not
pleased with any of you.
No, I'll upload this
and I'll refresh.
Oh, come on.
Oh, I didn't upload.
You actually have
to upload, like you
have to press the button.
So here we go.
We're uploading.
There we go.
There-- oh.
All right, you know what,
I'm going to roll with it.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take this picture,
and you'll see that
I have this map.
I have machines in all
of these data centers.
And I set them up really
easy, just with a script,
just like I showed you.
And what I'm going to do is
I'm going to take this picture
and bounce it
around our network.
And every time it hits a
different point on the network,
we're going to stamp it as if
it had like a little passport
stamp.
And you can see it happening
in live, real time.
We're actually traveling.
So we went from Taiwan
to Tokyo to Sydney
to Oregon to Iowa to Virginia
to London to Frankfurt and Sao
Paulo faster than I
could say it out loud.
We did it in 4.4 seconds
with 600 milliseconds or so
of processing.
What's great about
this is I didn't
have to do anything with the
network to get this to work.
It just worked out of the box.
And that's something
that I really like--
having tried other providers,
I get spoiled with this,
like not having to do a
tremendous amount of work,
which I shouldn't really say
that I'm happy with that.
My boss is in the room.
But it's OK.
I do like working.
I just-- I don't like
wiring up networking.
With that, I'm going
to switch to the preso,
and we're going to move on
to the next topic, which
is storage.
Where do I put my stuff?
So at the file
storage level, we have
two products, one which
we announced recently,
and Cloud Storage.
I'm going to talk through
both of those options, talk
why you'd choose
one or the other.
So Cloud Storage is
bucket-based storage.
We didn't-- everybody
does bucket-based storage.
It's kind of a common metaphor.
We didn't steal it from anybody.
With one set of
interfaces, even though I
have all these
different types I'm
going to talk about, every
time you deal with them,
whether you're going
through the console
or you're going through
CLI tools or SDKs,
it's the same commands,
just with different types
of storage.
What are those different types?
Well, we'll start with
multi-regional, which
is globally available storage.
This is for stuff that you
want to push out as close
to your users as possible.
You want it to be for
web content, or videos,
or mobile stuff.
You want it to be that when
your users go to get it,
it is as close to
them as possible.
As opposed to regional,
where what you really
are trying to do
is you're trying
to keep it as close to the
processing as possible.
Like this is big data
jobs, or maybe you
need to stay in certain
regions of the world.
You data, you can't leave it.
Or other reasons.
But here, the data
is only in one region
and it's close to the machines
you're using to process it.
Now, this doesn't mean that
you can't open up regional data
to the rest of the world,
like someone in California
can request something in
the European data center.
No, you totally can,
it's just the latency
is going to be a little
bit longer because it's not
duplicated as close to
the user as possible.
Then we have two other
options, nearline and coldline.
Both are longer term
storage options.
Nearline are for backups
and long tail media.
There's stuff that you
occasionally get to.
And it's planned that you'd
have regular access to it,
but it's not something that
you're getting every day.
And then coldline,
I like to say,
when you're downloading stuff
from coldline in one browser
window, you have your
resume open in another.
Because it's for compliance
and disaster recovery stuff.
Stuff that you hope
you never have to pull.
So you want to store that,
because you have to store it,
but you want to store it
as cheaply as possible
and never ever use it.
So that's what coldline is for.
This is kind of the
general cost in the US.
And they're different
in different regions,
but the deltas are always
pretty much the same.
Multi-regional is $0.026
cents per gigabyte per month.
Regional is $0.02 per
gigabyte per month.
Nearline is $0.01 per
And then coldline
is the cheapest
at $0.007 per
gigabyte per month.
There's also another cost
involved, which is retrieval.
So if I go and retrieve a
file from multi-regional or
regional, we don't charge you
for just accessing the file.
Whereas with nearline
and coldline,
because we want to encourage you
to kind of park them and leave
them, we have a $0.01 per
gigabyte charge for pulling
down from nearline, and a
$0.05 per gigabyte charge
for pulling down from coldline.
Again, that's probably
the least of your problems
then, but that's just now.
All right, we have
another option,
which is called Cloud
Filestore, which we, again,
released recently.
It's basically managed NFS,
and it's a shared file system.
You get really low latency
because you connect it
to the machines you're actually
using, usually in the same data
center.
There are two service tiers,
a premium and a standard.
It's basically-- it's NFS.
It's NFS that we manage.
So what should we use?
Well, NFS is
attractive, especially
if I'm using it
somewhere inside,
but the fact of the
matter is, I want to share
this data with the world.
I don't want to do a
lot of work to do that.
If I do NFS, then I have
to put some sort of system
to share on top of it.
And I have to manage that.
With Cloud Storage, as
you'll see in a second,
it just shares immediately
and it's pretty easy.
So I'm going to
use Cloud Storage.
So let me give you a quick
demo of Cloud Storage.
I'm going to switch
to the laptop again.
And here we go.
I'm on the laptop, great.
I'm going to go ahead
and create a bucket.
I'm going to call it tagger 102.
I'm just going
create a default one.
And you'll see that's it.
That's all I had to do.
It's already created.
I'm actually going to
upload files already.
So let's just upload all
the files from our app.
You'll see that they push
up, and they're going fast.
Fantastic.
Now they're in Cloud Storage.
And one of the things
I love about this is--
so let's see, Cloud
Storage, Gladiator.
I'm going to share it publicly.
And when I do that, I click
Public Link, boom, public.
That's how fast.
It's like already there.
You see I've got a URL for it.
Now, one of the
other files is Ewok.
I'm going to pick
because it's short.
And I'm going to do a
little URL walk in here.
Ooh, I did not mean that
pun and it came out.
Oh, no.
It's terrible.
And you'll see that
I can URL walk,
and I don't get it, because
those types of permission
sharing happen that fast.
So Cloud Storage is
sort of drop dead easy.
Like it just boom, works.
So with that, I'm going to
switch back to presentation.
All right, so you get
stuff to the Cloud Storage.
You can do it via
command line using
gsutil, which is equivalent to
gcloud, but for file storage
operations.
I can share publicly
by using gsutili iam
to do those operations.
Now, one thing I'll point
out is that I shared one file
within a private bucket.
I don't recommend doing
that, because that's
when bad things happen.
That's when human
error will take over
and you'll accidentally share
something you don't want to.
So what I like to do is
I have public buckets
and private buckets and
I don't mix the two.
But your mileage may vary.
Do what you will,
but that's my advice.
So my app needs to
talk to these things.
And to talk to the app, I
need use our client libraries.
Now, our client
libraries, you see here
the languages that are listed.
We also have REST APIs that
are reasonably well documented
if you need to do it
from another language.
But I'm going to use
PHP, because that's
what I used to
write this app and I
wanted to get it done fast.
Well, when you use PHP to move
files that have been uploaded,
you use move uploaded file,
because it's right on the nose.
That's the system
command to do it.
And you see, I take a
source and destination.
Now, to do this
using the SDK, I need
to do a little bit more code.
I need to use the right library.
I need to create
a storage client,
create a storage
bucket reference,
and then upload the file.
But not a tremendous amount
of more work in order
to accomplish the same thing.
So basically, I
just swap that in.
And then our app is
looking like this now.
I've moved all the images
to a cloud-based solution.
The application code is still
living on the same machine
as the database.
And we should fix that.
So let's go next and talk
about application storage.
Clearly, we get here, we get
the whole SQL versus NoSQL
conundrum.
I-- oh, my phone is going
off because I am dumb.
So SQL versus NoSQL, you
get in this conundrum.
And I don't clearly
have a winner,
although I do hate one of them.
But I won't tell you which.
Both of them are valid.
Both of them do things.
So let's talk about SQL first.
So Cloud SQL is
our tool for SQL.
It is a traditional SQL Server.
It is vertically scalable.
We provide managed backups
and easy to set up replicas.
And we make it easy to
do high availability.
Vertically scalable means
you can only get it so big.
And then if you
need more resources,
you need a more
powerful machine,
you have to come up with
some other solution.
We also have something
called Cloud Spanner,
which is for structured data.
It's SQL.
It's both highly available
and strongly consistent.
Now, those of you that know
CAP theorem may say that's
kind of impossible
in CAP theorem,
and databases, like
what are you doing here?
So what we did is we found the
guy who wrote the CAP theorem.
We hired him, made him a VP.
And he's kind of like,
uh, you could say it.
'Tis sort of close to the truth.
Basically, there are
reasons why we can say that.
There's a big white
paper, you can read it.
It is both of these
things and it is amazing.
It's globally distributed
and horizontally scalable,
which means you can
keep adding stuff.
If you need resources
in other places,
you can add them
in another place.
It's important to note that
this is cost effective at scale
for this app.
It would be like massive
overkill and my boss
would fire me,
because my bills would
be much higher than the real
value of Tagger the app, right?
So make sure that it's cost
effective for you to use it.
But if you have that type
of scale, it is amazing.
Let's talk about
our NoSQL option.
The two main ones that I
like, that I use a lot,
and I would use in this
sort of application
is Cloud Datastore
or Cloud Firestore.
Both are document-based.
Both are indexable.
And it's hard to tell sometimes
the difference between the two.
Like when you use
one versus another?
So I'll make it real easy.
If you're doing
stuff server side,
you probably want to
use Cloud Datastore.
You're talking from Google Cloud
somewhere else on Google Cloud.
You want that to
be Cloud Datastore.
If, on the other hand, you're
doing a lot with client work,
you're doing a
lot where you want
to bypass the server
completely and just
have data stored directly from
the client onto a datastore,
Cloud Firestore
is right for you.
Cloud Firestore is
sort of a marriage
of some of our Cloud
Datastore technology
and the expertise of
the Firebase team.
And so because of that, it has
a great web and mobile SDK,
and really works well
with those environments.
So which one should we use?
Well, I'm not
switching to NoSQL,
because it was written
in SQL, and I'm just--
I'm not switching to NoSQL.
That would be like
much more than I'd
want to do for an
experiment like this.
Cloud Spanner is
really overkill,
and so what I'm going
to do is use Cloud SQL.
So let me drive Cloud
SQL a little bit for you.
Here's our SQL machine.
I'm going to go ahead
and create an instance.
You'll see it gives me a choice
between MySQL and Postgres.
I'm going to choose MySQL.
You'll see here it gives me some
kind of pre-configured options
to make stuff easier.
I'm going to go with
a development server,
and then mess it up.
Let me do that.
I'm going to call this Tagger.
Let's see.
And then here's where
I can have some fun.
I can configure the type
of machine and storage.
So I'm going to start.
Right now, the
initial one is micro.
And you'll notice
over here that I
have a performance
kind of meter,
how performant this
machine is going to be.
I'm going go ahead and
change the processor.
When I change the
processor, you'll
see that I maxed out
network throughput.
So if you want more
network throughput,
add more processors to your
SQL boxes on Cloud SQL.
If I want better IOPS,
well, I can just--
hold on.
You'll see here
that as I increase
the number of IOPS, the
disk throughput and IOPS
and all that goes up.
And as I add more,
eventually, I max it out.
So if you need higher
performance out of your SQL
servers on Cloud SQL,
that's the way to do it.
And then I can also enable
automatic storage increases,
which is great.
Like if I'm getting
close to my disk,
instead of having
to have a big--
not that being here is
a problem, but if I'm
worried about that,
I can just enable it
so that it will grow
as my dataset grows.
So OK, I am going to
cancel out of that.
And then I'm going to
switch back to presenting.
All right, so how do I get
my data to include Cloud SQL?
Well, I do a
database dump, right?
Like I do MySQL dump.
And then I do gsutil and
copy it to Cloud Storage,
of all places.
Once it's in Cloud Storage,
I run sql import sql
to import that file.
And then after I import the
file, because you shouldn't
leave your SQL
dumps lying around
at a place that could be made
public, you delete the file.
Now-- oh, slight detour.
This pattern of pushing
stuff to Cloud Storage
and then pulling it down
elsewhere in Google Cloud
Platform, it's kind of common.
And I kind of see
Cloud Storage as sort
of hub between a lot of
different technologies.
You see this.
You have an application
running Cloud Functions.
You put a picture
in Cloud Storage.
And then manipulate it within
Vision API, or something else.
This pattern of being
a hub also applies
to Cloud Pub/Sub,
which I'm not really
going to show off because
it doesn't make sense
for this app.
But Cloud Pub/Sub
does for messages what
Cloud Storage does for files.
It basically acts as a
conduit in between all.
So it is a messaging bus that
does the publisher/subscriber
model.
You have many publishers or
one publisher, many subscribers
or one.
And then it'll make sure
that all the subscribers
get all the messages
from all the publishers.
I'll come back to that.
All right, now, some common
problems with doing Cloud SQL.
First one is you do glcoud
sql, and you import a file,
and you get an error.
This is an internal error.
OK, I didn't think it'd be
an external error, but fine.
All right, internal error.
And then you dig into it
and you set up verbose mode.
And it'll tell you,
guys, guys, this
was a MySQL error, which is
really not that much more
helpful.
And I have a bug filed.
I'm not bitter that
they haven't fixed it.
But how do you figure
out this problem?
So in the Cloud console, there's
this thing called Operations--
a tab called Operations.
At the top you'll see
that I have an error,
and it even includes
a line number.
So I can track this down
and maybe see what it is.
Turns out that MySQL dump,
if you had super privileges
locally, and you might have
because you're experimenting
with stuff and you
accidentally upped them,
like I totally did
in this case, you
can't do that because we
don't allow super privileges
on the box.
So watch out for that.
All right, so what if you
need something we don't offer?
Like I talked about Cloud SQL.
I talked about our products.
But maybe you need
Redis, or maybe you
need Mongo, or
Cassandra, or something.
Well, there's two options.
You could always build it by
hand using Compute Engine,
because it's just a VM.
You can install stuff on it.
We also have the thing called
Cloud Marketplace, which
just recently was renamed.
If you're familiar
with the platform,
it was called Cloud Launcher.
It's now Cloud Marketplace.
And there are
pre-built solutions
for things like Cassandra,
Redis, Mongo, CouchDB and more.
Now, it's important to
note that we will not
manage these for you.
We build them.
We like one-click
build these things.
But then managing
them is on you.
It won't be the way
our SQL boxes are.
All right, so here we are.
We've got our app from a web
application on a single server.
And now we're running
all our state elsewhere.
And we have all our
code on a single server.
This opens up a whole lot of
possibilities for us, right?
Because this is the
modern, the 12-factor app,
at least part of it.
Like we have application
code running in one place,
and we don't have
to state anywhere.
And so we can start
mucking around
with what we're doing
on the single server.
So let's talk about some of
our computing options, what
we use to build this stuff.
So how do we scale this system?
Now, there are a couple
of different ways
of scaling the system, like
what happens if Tagger becomes
a breakout success?
It won't happen, I know.
Fine.
Won't happen.
But what if it does?
Well, there are a couple of
ways of dealing with this.
The first way would be to use
a completely Compute Engine
solution, which is a combination
of using a managed instance
group and a network
load balancer.
So a managed
instance group, which
I'll talk about a little
bit more in a second,
is basically a
collection of VMs that
perform the same role of be
pointed at one load balancer.
And then our load balancers
are load balancers, which
are pretty straightforward.
They don't kind of
know what they are.
So talk a little bit about them.
Our instance groups, we
could say that they're
managed or unmanaged.
I chose managed for
that, because one
of the cool things about
a managed instance group
is you can say things like, all
right, because all the machines
are exactly the same,
you create a template
and it will create the same
machine over and over again.
You can say, I want processor
utilization to be at 60.
If it goes above 60,
spin up another box.
And because you have a
template, it can spin up the box
and it's perfect.
And it perfectly fits
what you're doing.
You also do unmanaged, where
you can build your own machines
and add them to it.
But then they could
be different profiles
of processor and memory
and that sort of thing.
So we can't really
auto-scale or auto-heal them.
So that's how you make
a collection of VMs
that all do the same task.
You throw a load
balancer on top of them.
And we have-- the
interface will show you
three different options.
We'll show you
HTTP, TCP, and UDP.
And you can make any
one of them local--
sorry, internal only.
So it doesn't get exposed
to the public internet.
So HTTP is our equivalent
of an L7 load balancer.
TCP, UDP is the
equivalent of an L4.
And then all of them can
be made internal only.
So we're at cloud conference
and I have not said Docker.
I have not said container.
And I have not serverless.
So what's going on, right?
I also haven't AI.
So we're big data, right?
But I'm going to focus on
container and serverless.
These are two terms
that you typically
want to maybe consider
moving your container,
your computing load to.
So what are containers,
for those of you
that might not be familiar?
Containers basically
consist of two things.
And this is-- if there are
container experts in the room,
I'm sorry.
I really oversimplified
it, but I
wanted to make it
really simple for people
who are not familiar with it.
So containers are
made up of two parts.
One, a package file containing
all of the code and runtime
components it takes to process
your app, or your microservice,
or whatever you're running.
And then you have
an environment that
tricks that package
into thinking
it's the only machine
that's running--
it's the only system
running on that machine.
Now, this is in
contrast to a VM,
where you carve off
bits of the machine
and say, use 16 megs of memory.
And if it only uses 8, well,
then that extra memory is gone.
You can't pull it back
because it's been carved off.
So doing it this
way, these containers
are all kind of tricked
into using the same kernel.
I don't know.
Maybe they're not tricked.
Maybe they're just induced
or encouraged or something.
But what that allows them to
do is spin up very, very fast,
because we don't have the
whole operating system tear up
and tear down.
And we can fit a
lot more of them,
because unlike a VM, where you
allocate blocks of resource,
these are just processes.
And they use exactly as
much memory and resources
as they need.
And then the rest is still
free for other containers
to pick up and use.
So there are two
container solutions
that I like to talk about
it at Google Platform.
You obviously can spin
up Docker on a VM.
And there's nothing
wrong with that.
And we actually make it
relatively easy to do.
But the two container
solutions I like to talk about
are Kubernetes Engine,
which is managed Kubernetes.
Anybody here familiar
with Kubernetes?
OK, that's intimidating.
So good, you all know
what Kubernetes is.
For those of you
that don't know,
Kubernetes is a container
orchestration system.
When you have one
container, it's
pretty easy to keep track of.
When you start having
20, 30 containers that
are all part of
different systems
that all need to be wired up to
different networking solutions,
it becomes challenging to
keep track of them all.
And so Kubernetes
manages that for you.
That's really
oversimplification.
Now, Kubernetes itself
is a very large bit
of software to manage.
Kubernetes Engine is probably
the easiest way to run it,
because we'll take
care of building
all the machines for
you and setting up
smart defaults for monitoring,
logging, DNS, service
discovery, and auto-scaling.
We also have this thing
called App Engine flexible,
which is much more simple.
You basically create a
custom runtime Docker image.
It's got to serve
up on port 8080.
And once you do
that, we will scale
it to as little or as much
as you need, starting at one.
So we'll leave it
running all the time.
You have one container
and one service
that's running on one endpoint.
And if you get a lot of traffic,
we'll just scale it out.
And if you get less traffic,
we'll scale it down.
Much more simple,
but it's better
when you have just
a very simple thing.
It's the quick and easy fix
for a lot of this stuff.
All right, so what
is serverless?
Serverless is a marketing term.
We all know it.
We're all in technology.
We all know it's
a marketing term,
because we know there's not some
sort of weird octopus creature
that these things
are running on.
It's a server, right?
There's a server somewhere.
And we know that
serverless is a lie.
But it describes something.
For you, the user, the
person consuming the service,
the server has
disappeared, because you
don't interact with it.
You don't ever have to
worry about setting it up,
or did I provision enough, or
does it have enough memory?
We take care of that for you.
So serverless
describes a service
where you pay as
you go for only what
you use, and you don't have
to be aware of the system it's
running on.
And that is actually
a really cool thing,
even if it is a marketing term.
All right, so serverless,
we have two products
that I kind of call
the serverless products
at Google Cloud Platform.
One is Cloud Functions,
which is function-based.
You write a function.
Send mail.
One function sends email, right?
You then attach them to events.
So someone writes a
file to Cloud Storage.
You can attach a Cloud
Function to that and send mail.
You can attach that event
to a Pub/Sub message.
You can attach that
event to a URL call.
So you can actually make URL
calls based on Cloud Functions
Now, if you need more
than just one function,
you need to chain a whole
bunch of environment stuff
together and create a
full application, well,
App Engine standard is
probably the way to go there.
We have a number of runtimes
for App Engine standard,
which we announced today
that we are releasing
some new ones in the
near future, which
is really exciting.
But basically, you have to
write in these languages
in order to use App
Engine standard.
And there's some restrictions.
Like if your software is
based on a C executable
that you wrote 10 years ago, you
can't pull that into App Engine
and have App Engine scale it.
But if you keep with those
constrained capabilities
and you just write code in
these runtime languages,
we will be incredibly,
incredibly rapidly
scale your application.
I have a demo--
I'm not going to show it--
where I take an App
Engine app that is cold,
that hasn't been hit in a day.
And I scale it from 0 to
8,500 queries per second
in less than five minutes.
So 8,500 QPS is pretty high,
but what does it really mean?
8,500 QPS is about 30
million requests an hour,
or what Wikipedia does
on an average hour.
So on App Engine, you
can scale from nothing
to a Wikipedia
level traffic site
in less than five minutes, which
is really, really cool and fun.
So the question is, so this
Tagger service, this thing,
should I switch this
over to one of those?
And my answer is, well,
it depends, right?
Typical weasel IT answer.
It depends, because if--
probably not, right?
It's just a simple
app that I'm running.
It's probably like a legacy
app that I've rolled over
and I need to keep going.
I don't know that I
would move it off of VM.
It's running fine,
just leave it on a VM.
But let's say I want
growth in this app.
Let's say I want it to
go bigger and better.
Then maybe I would push it to
containers and have it run with
a whole bunch of other similar
services so I get the most
resources out of my
hardware that I'm--
or the virtual hardware
that I'm pulling down.
Also, if I have this app that's
not very frequently used,
running a VM all
the time may also
be something that would
be too much of a cost.
So I might switch it
over to serverless
and take advantage of
the fact that serverless,
you only pay for what's used.
It would depend on
how much it's used.
So my answer is depends,
but for this app,
I don't see it lighting
up anytime in the future,
so I would probably
leave it on the VM.
So conclusions.
One-- so we started here.
Let me just kind of
recap what we did.
We had a single server app.
We moved it over to this sort
of configuration, single server,
which opened up a whole
bunch of possibilities
to us of maybe
switching to containers
or maybe switching
to serverless.
And we left our
images and our data
elsewhere, which was great.
We did this with Compute Engine
on the single server side.
We did it with Cloud SQL
on the database side,
and Cloud Storage
on the image side.
Now, I switched those
hexagons, because one
of the things that we do
is we kind of showcase
all of our products.
And I want to talk about just
how much we didn't talk about.
So we talked about a lot of the
compute stuff, which is great.
I'm happy.
We talked about a number of the
storage and database options.
We talked about
networking and we
talked about big data, the
Cloud Pub/Sub reference.
Cloud Vision API, I cut a demo.
So we didn't talk
about that at all.
We talked about Cloud SDK.
We talked about some of
the management tools.
But the entirety of Cloud
Platform is much bigger.
There's a lot more stuff there.
I hope that as you look through
this display of our stuff,
that you see places
where you want to go.
I hope that I kind of
showed you some of it,
but we can see that
there's a lot more.
And if only there was
some place that you
could go to which would
provide you with answers
about the rest of
the platform, I
don't know, like some
sort of conference,
it would be great if you could
answer some of these questions
about what these
things do elsewhere.
[MUSIC PLAYING]